So today we're going to be
making something which has
been called the Bernoulli
cups.
Whether that's an appropriate
name or not is something that
I won't comment on.
All we need for it are these two
polystyrene cups that I'm
going to arrange end
to end somehow.
And I'm just going to tape
them together around the
middle, like so.
A little bit more, maybe.
Right, that should do the job,
apart from the couple of
elastic bands.
These are probably not quite
long enough, but we can do
something about that.
We'll just fold one through
the other and make a loop,
double-length elastic band.
That's all we need.
So let's go and find out what
this does, for which we'll
need a bit more room, I think.
OK, we're in the gallery of
the lecture theatre, which
obviously is the best place for
launching flying objects,
which hopefully is what this
is about to become.
Well, first of all, I have to
just wind the elastic band
around the middle, and hopefully
wind it on itself so
it doesn't pop out.
I wonder if I'm doing
it the right way.
I can't really remember what's
the best way of doing it.
And then I'll hold on
to that a bit, hold
it a bit like that.
And, mm-hmm.
Mmm, yeah, flying would be a
generous interpretation for
what just happened.
Oh, yeah, that's better.
You sort of saw it loop up a bit
before it ran out of steam
and then kind of plummet.
Well, luckily, I've got
plenty more, so we can
have a few more goes.
Ooh, a bit of a misfire.
So what I think we saw there was
- well, first of all, the
cups fell a lot more
slowly than you
might think they would.
They drifted down
pretty slowly.
But also, I don't know if you
saw at the start, when the
cups were moving quite fast,
they sort of curved up a bit
before drifting back
down again.
So there's obviously some
effect going on there.
Now, aerodynamics is pretty
fiendish to explain.
And getting two people to
agree on the best way of
explaining something, it's as
likely to end in a fist-fight
as not, I think.
So I'm going to tread
quite carefully.
But one of the things that I
think is going on here is
something called the
Magnus effect.
And this applies to objects that
are spinning as they move
through the air.
So it applies to footballs
when - this is what makes
footballs curve when
the players
apply spin to the ball.
So with the cups, as they move,
they're sort of spinning
backwards like this.
And you get sort of air
entrained around the cups,
spinning with them.
And that sort of creates a
higher air pressure area
underneath the cups, and sort
of lower pressure on top.
And that supports some of the
weight of the cup, even all of
the weight of the cup
at the start.
And you get this sort of kicking
up like that, and then
just gradually slowly
drifting down.
And then eventually the spin
runs out of oomph, and it just
falls on the ground.
This is pretty easy to make,
so have a go yourself.
See what you think.
And see if you can come up with
a better explanation than
I have given.